tout le monde est amené chaque jour à
côtoyer les transports les
infrastructures publiques ou les grands
ensembles urbains
durant deux jours vous aurez l'occasion
de regarder d'un oeil nouveau
tous ces bâtiments en découvrant leur
architecture comme par exemple une
visite de la gare et ses abords samedi
17 octobre à 11 heures
c'est vraiment une occasion unique pour
approfondir la connaissance de ce
territoire
la gare elle est empruntée par des
milliers de personnes tous les jours
pour autant qui connaît l'histoire de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines
terminus du rer c une garde qui est né
en 1975 au milieu des champs voilà c'est
une histoire une aventure urbaine
architecturale assez exceptionnel
vendredi 16 octobre vous pourrez visiter
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui a été inauguré en 1993 et à 11h30
vous pourrez observer la rue colbert
principales artères du centre commerçant
les publics intéressés peuvent aussi
enchaîné les visites et au fil de visite
on peut avoir un aperçu vraiment très
globale des différents éléments forts de
l'hyper centre de montigny une
conférence sur le quartier saint quentin
en présence de yves droz un urbaniste et
architecte pendant quinze ans du coeur
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
aura lieu vendredi à 19 heures il
reviendra sur la naissance du quartier
architecture de montigny à la voulu être
comment dire
en confort d'échelle conforme avec
l'espace sur lequel s'installe c'est à
dire le long des grandes avenues
vous avez des grands immeubles le long
des rues vous avez des immeubles plus
petit dans laxe des avenues vous avez
des grands équipements solaires c'est
une mise en scène pour moi la ville est
un théâtre
les rendez vous durant ces deux journées
se feront in situ et sans réservation
dans la limite des places disponibles